welcome to this video playing sonars
Sunil's dunno finland the Queens gambit
accepted yeah funny this is a funny line
black is grabbing material I really have
to check now come on yeah I will I can
explain a bit about this later it's an
opening line okay so bit weird that he's
taking time here because it's not it's
very much forced almost so let's see
going to go night be five now on Queenie
to first yeah me do this now night to d6
yeah maybe to check go there immediately
to prevent him from castling
k Queen f4 on what else
yeah Quinn d3 is also possible let's do
this if he goes back I can still decide
to again play 26 and I can go to c5 you
can go to see 5 ok he doesn't how do i
play now yeah maybe still queen d 6 and
then let's reconsider now I really I
don't want to draw that's not the point
Queen f4 maybe I've got queen of five
but then maybe queen to c7 and tending
Bishop c2 with a very annoying pin the
castles now Bishop c2 is a is a very
very annoying pin isn't this good
attending 92 for example yeah the one
issue is that here this and he has no
development whatsoever right before I
before I probably Knight d4
I really don't see how is getting out of
the pin maybe Queen g6 intending at five
is somehow possible but that's not
looking any good I mean it's not looking
great i mean yeah maybe you can still
play it as bad as it looks otherwise 92
look so really deadly I think maybe
really Queen 36 + f5 Queen g69 h4 you
can play em can play Queen g-form
okay um if he goes Queen g6 what can i
play Bishop c5 is also on move Bishop c5
then possibly rook e8
it's also 95 95 f 5
95 is also not winning
not seeing a win here this f five moves
somehow always happening Bishop c5
rookie idea we recklessly holding
195
yeah i I don't I don't see I don't see a
direct win it's quite weird but I don't
see it
this is getting the porn back and then
go from them which is not bad but I was
thinking that your queen buddy I was
thinking that there should be a director
that is requested ah come on really ok
take back accept it it's still
interesting this position so I I'll do
them do the acceptance
yeah Jai have to have to do it otherwise
i'm not getting the porn back at all 'if
I've there's Bishop d5 important winning
an exchange yes I guess here to make it
difficult time to play Bishop d7 oh I
thought it would be I came yeah sorry
this was a misconception b6 is not
helping him because it it makes the
night less stable
now he's still in a pin the slack resign
it's a double attack yeah it it probably
i don't know it's interesting if if what
the computer is saying about about all
the same was interesting really ok we
were here and yeah the computer gives
this move and queen f-4s the best reply
we had this intermezzo then i went here
and he went here computer now wants to
go to age form well this is any bad no
gives white a slight edge but not that
we know anything the ship c2 and it
gives Bishop before now with with a wide
advantage okay he went here and now i
have a win but what is the win this I
thought rook e8 but I didn't see her
didn't see a win here this wasn't my
problem takes and takes rook t1 and I
didn't really see why this was winning
now okay it is not winning like instant
I was thinking something like this but
the computer and stop her she gives this
place plus 2 which is mmm Ted optimistic
I think white has a very very big
advantage but two pawns with equal
material is this really a lot I'm not
sure that the game continuation was much
worse actually it gets it gets to the
same position type but II five now was a
better defense check yeah this is just
excellent for wide and take quickly
quickly crumbled yes you cannot defend
this position it's too much I could have
taken be seven HR
strange yeah but it is so overwhelming
with them with the two bishops in an
open position yes this week pawn in
addition so it said simply excellent
yeah alright thanks for watching